rick santorum served as a senator from
the state of pennsylvania for more than
a decade he then became a political
commentator tucker recently spoke to
rick santorum for a brand new episode of
tucker carlson today but the
conversation wasn't just about politics
rick santorum shared a deeply personal
story about the most challenging moment
in his life here's part of the of the
conversation
[Music]
couples find out that their child is
disabled and they don't want their child
anymore
and it was stunning to me that she would
make that admission that we would call
the ranks of the disabled
and so i that was a central part of my
uh of of my
debate and so i got up and i said
um
many stories but one was
i said my wife at the time karen was 19
weeks pregnant i said you know uh i have
a sonogram schedule we have a science
description of next week at 20 weeks
and
you know i don't know whether my child
is going to be healthy or not but if
it's if my child is somehow not
healthy i'm not going to kill it why
would i kill my child just because my
child has a medical problem i mean
you love the gift that god gives you for
however long god gives it to you and
that you know that that happens with all
of our children we don't know how long
we're to have our children how long
we're going to be alone you're going to
make me great no that's and and so and
so i say that and and
and a week later we have the sonogram
and um we're sitting there in this sauna
and over going over this one spot in the
sonogram and drops the the wand and says
i have to get the doctor
doctor comes in does it
he looks at me this is
cold as i can ever remember he looks at
me says your son has a fatal defect and
is going to die
and and so this was during my time where
i'm sort of
growing in my faith and having this
experience that i talked to about
finding the lord
taking on this this great what i thought
was an important moral cause for the
country
and then boom
you know and i i remember having this
conversation with god and said you know
here i am trying to follow your path and
you take my son
and so it was
devastating
we did everything we could to try to
save his life we had went up to
children's hospital in philadelphia and
had intrauterine surgery to try to fix
the problem
and end up see karen got an infection
and delivered our little boy he lived
for two hours
and
i thought
you know
what
what are you doing why are you doing
this and you know it's just you know god
why why why you know all the the
greatest question everybody who goes
through this tragery why why did this
happen to me and
um
and what happened my wife
it wasn't me it was my wife who made
it all come together
she
every time we had we got pregnant karen
would keep a diary to describe the
pregnancy so she could share it with the
kids and say oh this is what it was like
and to share these notes that was you
know she was a neonatal intensive care
note so she she always
pregnancies were
just a really joyful time and she would
keep notes and she she was keeping notes
about our son so she kept writing these
letters to him
hope he'd sub he'd read them oh
so she wrote these letters
and at the end when she died she kept
writing because it was her way to just
get this stuff out
so she wrote this and and her mother
read it who had lost a child 50 years
ago
and from the sid's death and
it just broke her up and she said you
have to publish this you have to publish
these letters
and so anyway eventually we put a little
catholic publisher published it sold out
25 000 copies
and it's still around but it's called
letters to gabriel
what an unbelievable story
and you can watch tucker's full
interview with rick santorum
on taco carlson today by going to
foxnation.com what an amazing show that
tucker has there hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else